whoa reject nation it's greg alba here
huh and it's john here John's officially
moved in return to the red couch back to
the living room
yay insidious the last key not insidious
chapter four this is a prequel chapter
point five let's do this why beat around
the tushy anymore
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
people who need help with matters that
can't be explained come to me these
hauntings can be terrifying days I
should know I've faced many evils
[Music]
[Music]
personal keys on the head fingers that's
crazy
[Music]
to end this evil I need to go deeper
into the further
[Music]
[Applause]
what like the I'm an jihoh jihoh cool
I'm a slightly confused I remember we
read the plot synopsis yesterday and it
said that it was set before the events
of the first couple insidious movies
this still looks like a sequel that's
going where is she's gonna be going back
to her roots just put an end to
something that occurred before the first
insidious movies yeah that's what I
gathered from it I mean they even showed
like images of the first insidious for a
brief moment and that she's saying how
she needs to go even like further into
the further deeper into the further you
know that's what it look like to me I
would have taken this as a part four and
that's going back to it's like sort of
hybrid pretty cool in a way yeah well I
feel like at a certain point it might
not even matter you know because it's
just all different paranormal cases that
Alisa's take it on I think it looks
really solid and before when I would
hear like January release I would be
like know about this I feel over the
past couple of years we've been getting
some pretty damn good horror movies that
are January releases from Blum House get
out or January February this past year
and and then the year before was the
visit that's so I feel like that
January is not a terrible month anymore
at least for Blum houses horror films
well yeah now they're smart they know
like it's a sparse month we can clean up
you know yeah what a good movie and the
cinematography looks great no this is a
different director this time around Adam
robitille hell yeah the guy did taking
of Deborah Logan yeah and I think it
looks pretty good the effects look
awesome it looks like it's gonna go
crazier with its ghost effects and like
that room where it was just a bunch of
ghosts coming out of there like oh yeah
that was intense and I like the effects
of the key finger whatever that is it's
like it's holding the keys yeah yeah and
that's what I love is like that's what I
love about the insidious movies and
that's what gives them their flavor to
me is that sort of like fun
house vibe the designs in the world and
stuff like that I was imagine like the
conjuring is more down to earth in its
ghost story vibe at least as of yet yeah
but these like you know the imagination
is part of what draws me in and I love
having at least Tucker in specs is kind
of the central characters who guide us
through this video like the ghost with
the key fingers it's so eerie and it's
so good gothic and stuff like that you
know seeing the the further the extended
reaches of the further part of me
worries a little bit cuz I'm like you
know how how big are we gonna make it
you know what are the rules gonna be I
always worry that it's gonna fall off
the tracks a little bit but you know at
least the images we saw here look super
chilling and intriguing and stuff like
that and yeah it's a more personal story
for release this time around - yeah it
seems like it's got everything the
insidious movies all the earmarks you
know all the designs and all the unique
ghosts you know things and you know the
personal story with the lease and all
that my first work about in cities for I
was thinking like does anyone really
care about this and now watching the
trailer I'm like I care about it I want
to check this out this looks like it
could be a pretty damn good horror movie
yeah good good will towards the first
three and oddly I like I now I just
wonder what the other plot of this movie
is with that woman and it has to be a
prequel what am I talking about because
at least dies in the first one yeah in
case she comes back apart - okay
disregard anything I said I feel like
every other insidious movie should be
about a live Elise and every other
insidious movie should be about deadly
yeah yeah
well guys thanks for tuning in hey hey
and subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell followed a John
Humphrey on Instagram and Twitter of
course check out our patreon patreon
comm slash the real rejects become a
patreon eject today my friends come
cuddle with us a lot of fun ice will
write you a letter